but i believe the legacy and the
ancestry of black americans is being
insulted every single day
i will not pretend to be a victim in
this country i know that that makes many
people on the left uncomfortable
and democrats on the house judiciary
committee were extremely uncomfortable
as candace owens just slashed at the
narratives of the people like nadler
and ted lou in fact when c-span tweeted
out the video of the confrontation with
lou
it racked up 4.47 million views
in less than 24 hours it's a twitter
record for that network
joining me now in her first interview
since the explosive hearing
is candace owens herself she's the coms
director for turning point usa and leo
terrell
civil rights attorney we have both sides
uh uh represented here tonight candace
why do you think that your moment and i
watched it from beginning to end has
drawn such attention
and what has been the reaction to you
personally
since well i think it drew
attention for a lot of reasons i think
in many ways people on the right felt
vindicated
i know that there are a lot of moderate
people that came over and realized that
what i was talking about were actually
real issues in black america i touched
upon the illiteracy rates
75 percent of black boys in california
not being able to read is a problem in
black america
white nationalism when black on black
crime
90.1 of all homicides against black
americans
are performed by other black americans
the entire hearing in my opinion was a
hoax
the continued hoax on black america
which comes to us from democrats who
want us ultimately to fail by focusing
on something
that is not harming us when you look at
all the other issues that we are facing
uh now leo you watched i'm sure at least
part of what candice said yesterday your
reaction
well i just see right now candace always
is giving 15 minutes of fame and just
give me 30 seconds to prove my point
she just again assumed that all
democrats are hoping that black people
fail
on her on her interview with c-span she
says that the word
nationalism has been compromised or
poisoned by elitists
tell that to the people in
charlottesville she didn't try to put
herself in the same category
of donald trump talking about the false
narrative but the part that was so
insulting when she was promoting her
employer
and said that she went to jerusalem and
not a single democrat went there ms
always let me tell you 72 percent of
jewish americans
voted for democrats so you did a great
job of promoting yourself and playing
the victim and by the way
it's not just black people who are not
stupid by what you said americans were
not stupid because i listened to
everything you just said
and i hope you can challenge what i said
about the number of blacks number of
jews who support democrats but you did a
good job of marketing yourself today
putting yourself in the same boat
as the president good job candace all
right so the personal attack i just
wanted for the record
personal attacks continue that leah was
a you you're attacking her
character she's meant she's missing
you're attacking her character and what
she said
you're not a leader in my opinion in my
opinion
let me speak that wasn't ad hominem
attack and it's childish and i'm not
going to play these playground tactics
with you
i'm going to keep the focus on black
america and the things are actually
impacting us this is not this is an
adult conversation that needs to be had
okay the shooting's in chicago it was
laura ingraham who
who hosted and had a real conversation
with people that were living in that
neighborhood about things that are
affecting them and ultimately
this is why the blexit movement grows
this is why blacks are exiting the
democrat party
because ad hominem attacks are not
making people feel better about
themselves
ad hominem attacks are not going to
impact our financial our financial
situation in black america it's
unfortunate
because you consider yourself a civil
rights leader you're just attacking me
you're just attacking me you haven't
even seen
anything no
does anyone laura watch does anyone
watching your program honestly believe
what she just said i'll give you a
straight
she said democratic parties want black
people to fail you
let's see see see those are talking
points miss owens because you know deep
down inside
just because you disagree with the
democrats you cannot assume that
democrats want black people
to fail that's what you just said on
national tv i did and i believe that and
i will back that up
okay
i think a lot of democrat leaders are
freaking out
and tried to kill her yesterday at that
hearing because they don't want
what she is saying to take hold in
other parts of the black community leo i
i honestly believe that i know candace
and what was said about her implies
laura was disappointed
i do and that's why i want to have a
conversation about these
underlying issues that's why we went to
chicago to do that forum that's why we
want to
hear from the neighbors that are hurting
in englewood in the englewood
neighborhood
they're hurting they're really hurting
they're not hurting mostly because of
of of black of avoid nationalism that's
that's
that's always going to be a problem but
that is correct why they're hurting
here's
my request here's my request here's my
request laura i would like to
go to chicago with you and debate miss
owens on that issue
i would love to go on why do we need to
debate why don't you want to be here why
do you want to debate
because i want you to discuss you got to
hear about other people you want to
debate
that's like you just made it the most
the most diverse diverse party
let me speak let me speak i have not
said a single thing attacking your
character because i don't need to
i am confident in my ideas i am
confident in the fact that black america
is waking up and realizing that we have
been missing out i am confident
that the biggest issue facing our
community is father absence
which further deconstructs everything
that is happening stop stop cutting me
off
okay you have a cat every year
she has basically said that every
democrat the most diverse party of
minorities
of people of color she has just said on
national tv over and over again
that the democrats want black people to
fail miss owens that's not the person
those are your words that's not true
that's not true leo
that's a fact that i would take i would
actually take what leo said with
with with a greater sense of you know
belief and credibility
had leo you said something similar every
time
anita lowey or you know or elijah
cummings
just imparts the worst motives on people
who disagree with them
on policy and it and it happens far too
often so the worst motives ever come on
the other side are you a white person
then you have too much white
privilege then you need to put you you
need to sit down and let someone else's
truth be heard
i think leo you got your truth out you
got your truth out candace got her truth
out
and i think we do want to have problem
solving done on both sides we want
problem solving on this show
and that means we have different points
of view heard and leo you can come come
to chicago candace
thank you we actually could roll up our
sleeves and get something done i think
if the three of us actually wanted to do
that so
uh guys thank you so much candace great
to have you great to have you on